hey everybody okay so a couple things go
over here real fast uh first of all next
week I'm gonna be starting something
called a commentary week which is just
exactly what sounds like it's a bunch of
commentaries on my videos cuz I haven't
done a mini in a while and I'm just
wondering which ones do you guys really
want to see you so go the comments below
and tell me which ones you really like
to see it's old or new or whatever and
I'll talk about them the second thing is
that this coming weekend I got all
makaan which is in Michigan and you know
it's just next week so I figured just
give a shout out shout out dresses right
there you can check it out go ahead and
see if that's something you want go to
local rebo's gonna be there all sorts of
good people so go ahead drop by check it
out but that's not what you want to hear
about you want to hear about my thoughts
on the hobbit the desolation of smaug
because it has been so freakin long
since like that movies come out and I
only now like yesterday finally got a
chance to see it it was like and there's
no showings for it they're all like one
showing a day or something if I only
found one movie theater showing in the
week we got a couple around so that's an
interesting sign uh and like I said just
a real impromptu thing because people
then ask you what you think what you
think so this is just a fast video
saying what I thought about as well as
ginza Mayer news out the first film if
you don't know I really liked the first
Hobbit despite the fact I know it's you
know not the most focus and not really a
big grand epic grain thing but I really
like it
because I always said it's like the
Fellowship of the Ring I felt I never
got because I felt fellowship was
supposed to start off like a really
small story they got bigger and bigger
bigger until it turns into the grand
epic I never thought they got the small
stuff right it was edited too fast
they're a bunch of weird close-ups and
stuff so I really like The Hobbit this
was the first time I felt like I could
just relax in middle-earth and enjoy it
and enjoy the Shire and enjoy the people
land and I greatly enjoyed it even
though what everybody says is right I
know it's they had to put in a lot of
filler and stuff but but I liked a lot
now we got the sequel here we got the
desolation of smaug and I was
we shocked to find I really did enjoy it
which I could be opening a can of worms
with that I don't know because I think
the feedback seems to be that critics
are leaning towards not liking it where
people are served but leading towards
enjoying it because there's a lot more
action and I think mainly that a lot
more action going on I thought I really
couldn't get into it uh the first third
I was liking fine
it's them going through this forest and
they come across all these spiders and
that serve a fun scene there's this guy
that turns into like a bear and a man
and it's like that stuff's gray and I
mean that stuff's a lot of fun to come
across these elves and there's this love
triangle which you think I would hate
and the actual the actual triangle
element I don't like it's between
freckles elf
Orlando Bloom and this the other
good-looking dwarf there's like only two
good-looking dwarves and the romance
between her and the dwarf is actually
fine the whole Orlando Bloom things
seems really pointless but obviously the
romance between them is fine but it's
like then she's chasing after and when
she finds out he like has this poison
she has to save him and it's like you
haven't known each other for that long
this is very Disney ish you know
suddenly I'm devoted and I will follow
him and I will go across the lands even
when they know the great evil is coming
which we all know what that is so that
was a little weird but the actual talks
between them I felt were fine the going
down with the barrels and the water and
stuff wonderful action scene I mean I
was just like having a ball I'm like
holy smokes what you know all my friends
everything we're saying we're right like
this is really fun and I'm really
getting into this but then they sort of
go to this other town and it's this dark
depressing place and at first they have
a cool establishing try you think it's
gonna be neat it is for a few minutes
but there's a lot of time dedicated to
this town and just how rotten it is
for it but okay Lord the rigs they have
a lot rotten places and stuff like that
well what's the next place we're gonna
do well now we get to go inside a cave
just this big dark empty cave oh well
okay that that's not the most exciting
Oh Gandalf going somewhere where is he
going well he's going to a very dark
grey depressing looking place where the
evil that everybody knows what it is and
what its you know what's coming is
coming so and there's a lot of build up
for it and it's just cutting back and
forth between like three or four
subplots going on and I was trying to
ask myself why did it bother me here and
not in The Hobbit because I totally
acknowledge a hobbit had a lot of a lot
of filler I think what did it for me was
that in the first film even when there
was filler you were still focusing on
this group it's still this group that
you're following through and you're a
part of the adventure it's almost like
you're you're with the group going
through it here they split up I don't
think you can do that in a story like
this because when you do that in a story
of this is a smaller story the Hobbit is
a smaller story and the first film I
thought they got that okay that there
was definitely some big action scenes
but it's still in this small group um
you know even the the big climax you
know it serve going through this cave
and all these things are chasing them
and stuff but it's a chase it's not a
big war a big battle you know so it
works okay uh this was trying to do
everything like it was a big grant epic
battle that you can cut in between three
or four things going on because it's so
big and it's so grand and it's not it's
not big and grand it's not supposed to
be big and grand so when you see Bilbo
talking to the dragon which you get sick
of really quickly um when you first see
him it's so cool but then you just he
sunscreen far too long and you just see
him as an effect and not a character
anymore
you're watching him talk to this thing
and then you cut what's going on with
Gandalf wha
okay well Oh No kidding Sauron you don't
say yeah okay well alright let's come
back to out the dragon wait no we got
the little triangle thing going on there
okay oh can we move that I wanted to
okay well now back to the right way away
we get these uh orcs sneaking up and
well at least it's the great big bad
work that's been chasing oh wait no no
he's uh he's off with Sauron and he sent
his second-in-command to go after the
doors because there's a lot of boiling
blood between them apparently him and
Legolas because they have a staredown
and the movie ends with him like chasing
after the orc and we don't know what
happens so it's like oh I really wanna
know what's gonna happen there and then
finally we get back to the damn dragon
they say about five words and then we
come back together but now we come back
to the orc so that we come and I don't
care it's it's really fascinating that
the last half I say I'd say almost the
last two-thirds of this movie and just
just how phenomenally bored I was I
really think the problems I have with
this film like the criticisms I'm making
are ones that everyone else made of the
first film but my big the big difference
I have is that I really think by
splitting it up it made the story move
so much slower and you couldn't get the
investment in there as much alright at
least I couldn't because I know a lot of
people saw it and really got into it and
kudos man me it's not like it awful film
I mean it's not really bad it just it
didn't grab me I mean like all the all
the conflicts all the character building
and stuff with the exception of of the
of the Shelf which I never get yeah it's
like what the he oaf is that what they
call the male's I don't get that it's
like saying you know if a woman comes
say hey she woman whatever um you know
between her and the dwarf light like
that's fine you know for the first man
that was good character building but
after that you get some stuff with you
know
other Dwarfs like trying to find their
way in you know and even when they're
trying to get into this door that's like
that's very similar to the when they try
and get into the mines of moria but
whatever I might the mines of moria like
looking very very blue and very pretty
and Isis and everything and this is just
great it's like we have three or four
different gray dark unpleasant settings
that were constantly cutting back and
forth to and that's not fun and the big
chase with the dragon at the end goes on
forever because you can't look at
anything it's all in the dark and even
that's not too much fun because you know
there's a scene where they get in these
little sur like these rollercoaster
carts or something I think oh this is
gonna be like Temple of Doom or
something gonna fly around no no just
the dragon serve goes by and they're
trying to turn on this great big machine
that does some cool stuff and the dragon
just goes wah
big speech about how nasty I am and that
that's all the dragon does like he's a
bore um so yeah I to me I thought the
first film I really liked Bilbo I really
liked whatever the main two are except
for getting his name is I really like
Gandalf in the first one I I'm one of a
few people I actually like that
conversation between Gandalf and Saruman
and Galadriel and stuff I liked that
conversation because again I like I like
seeing this background I like seeing
these characters it seemed like there
wasn't that much of the characters
working off each other like I said a
little bit the end or before the big
fight with the dragon
you know Bilbo sir talks the dwarfs and
that's a nice scene but how long is this
like two and a half hours and then you
have the scene with the with the elf and
the dwarf and then a little bit in the
city with this family that we set up but
it seemed to me like they were just
trying to make this great big grand
story out of something that's really
small and I know everybody says that was
the first one I I know that but to me it
still felt like a small story you know
that that has some big things happening
but when you compare it to lower the
Rings it's not very big and they kept it
to this one group it's this one
adventure it's a journey it's an
unexpected journey
this one they're trying to make into an
epic and it for me it didn't work but I
know a lot of people that really liked
it and really got into it so like I say
if you do it's not like a god-awful flag
it just it didn't do anything for me I
just thought it was kind of boring it
would except to the first third I got
into that okay so um yeah like I said
that's about it just a quick follow up
cuz I know everyone's asking like what
you think a hobbit which is the guy
hobbits so those are my thoughts I'm
sorry if they don't match your see you
know that's just that's opinions um and
yeah let me know in the comments what
commentaries you like to see me do and
also uh hopefully you can go and see me
in Michigan hopefully I'll see you guys
there take care